Батареї в українських оселях теплішають,
а з ними зростають цифри у платіжках.
І оскільки комунальні послуги, схоже, дешевшати, не будуть,
українцям доводиться оформлювати субсидії.
А їх з 1 жовтня нараховують по-новому.
Що змінилося для споживачів, хто тепер матиме право на субсидію
і як перевірятимуть прохачів допомоги?
За новими правилами, гроші отримуватимуть
не підприємства-надавачі послуг, а люди.
Причому ви можете самі обирати, куди перераховуватимуть кошти.
Це може бути або спеціальний рахунок в "Ощадбанку",
звідкіля вони списуються автоматично.
Причому якщо під час опалювального сезону родині
вдасться заощадити кошти,
навесні їх можна буде зняти з рахунку і забрати собі.
Або іще один варіант - субсидію можна буде отримати
у відділеннях "Укрпошти" чи на власний рахунок,
відкритий в одному з 38-ми уповноважених банків.
Цією послугою можна скористатися,
якщо заздалегіть подати документи - до 15 жовтня.
І  вже з отриманих коштів згодом самостійно сплачувати комунальні рахунки.
Чи перевірятимуть прохачів субсидії?
Так. По державних реєстрах система збиратиме інформацію
про претендентів на допомогу та шукатиме невідповідності і можливе шахрайство.
Також в Україні хочуть запровадити перевірки допомоги,
наданої три роки тому.
Якщо виявлять порушення, гроші змусять повернути.
Загалом же відмовити у субсидії, приміром, можуть українцям,
чия опалювальна площа перевищує
120 кв метрів для квартири, і 200 квадратів - для будинку.
Також серед причин для відмови -
наявність у родини дорогого відносно нового автомобіля
або хоча би одна дорога покупка на понад 50 тисяч гривень.
Якщо у родини є борги за комунальні послуги на понад 340 гривень,
субсидію також не дадуть.
Тому слід буде або сплатити борги або домовитися
про їх реструктуризацію з компанією-постачальником.
Втім, навіть якщо людина не в змозі погасити борг,
але обійтися без субсидії не може, допомогу їй таки можуть дати -
за рішенням спеціальної комісії при місцевих органах влади,
яка після перевірки може призначити субсидію.
Якщо родина вже отримувала допомогу на оплату комунальних послуг,
то перерахунок у новому опалювальному сезоні буде автоматичним.
Заяву на отримання субсидій мають подавати лише ті,
хто претендує на неї вперше.
Причому аби оформити субсидію не обов’язково стояти в чергах,
це можна зробити онлайн.
Наразі субсидію на оплату комунальних послуг призначено майже трьом мільйонам родин.
У держбюджеті на наступний рік на це заклали  понад 47 млрд гривень -
що майже на 8 млрд менше, ніж цьогоріч.
Чи означає це, що субсидій буде менше?
Схоже, що так. Адже, як зазначили у міністерстві соцполітики,
через збільшення мінімальної зарплати та індексацію пенсій
доходи українців зростають, і, відповідно, дедалі менше громадян
матимуть право на державну допомогу.